welcome back to Las Vegas now it's
officially spooky season which means
it's time to gear up for Halloween and
here with some costume ideas fall
outfits we're talking all things candy
anything that falls under the category
of Halloween we have Haley harzinski
from downtown Summerlin Haley always so
great to see you great to see you so
Downtown Summerlin has a little bit of
everything for everyone especially when
it comes to fall shopping so tell us
some of the stuff that you brought in
today I see sparkly candles over there
absolutely so nothing says you know
Halloween like candy so you know we have
it sugar on property and I love these
oversized candy you can give them as
gift boxes and then Sur La top has
really great cookie kits so you can
bring those and do a little cookie
baking with your kids and things like
that so just come on down to downtown
summer just fill up on everything sweet
you can get your sweet fix that's for
sure imagine you know how people get
really excited when you go
trick-or-treating and they have the
full-size candy bars what if you were
just handed this while you're a
trick-or-treating exactly right you
would go back to that house over and
over again but always something fun to
find and it's sugar and let's move on
over here again sparkly you're calling
my name over here yeah we have so many
places that have a variety of Halloween
decor and fall Decor uh this is from
Macy's and this is just a really fun
skull that has a little bit of bling I
love bling and then of course Bath and
Body Works for everything fall
everything from lotions to candles to
plug-ins you name it your house will be
smelling perfect and when it comes to
clothing or let's say Halloween costumes
it's always kind of fun to put together
your own DIY costume do you think you
could find everything you need at
downtown Summerlin for any costume of
course you know and that's always best
it's a DIY a costume we have everything
from h m to Urban Outfitters and so you
just come down with the idea piece it
all together and then that's what makes
it unique to you and also what I love
about Downtown Summerlin is every year
you guys really get in the spirit
whatever holiday it is Christmas
Halloween tell us about the parade this
year it looks like so much fun Yep this
year we brought back the parade every
Friday and Saturday in October and we
actually are bigger we added three brand
new floats and then we added Decor
throughout the entire property so we
have 12 foot skeletons all throughout
the property which is ghouls it's so fun
you guys always go bigger and better
every year and when can people come see
you is it free tell us all the details
every Friday and Saturday in October at
7 pm on Park Center Drive and free and
open to the general public well you have
all of our Halloween and fall needs and
again if you just want to go shopping
and find a cute Fall outfit you know
you're going to find it at downtown
Summerlin I spent a lot of time there
Haley thank you so much for being here
JC I'll send it over to you all right
thank